you know the digital pitch kind of
founders weren't able to fly everyone
was really worried about what was going
to happen the past couple of months
but the digital pitch actually
accelerated uh the fundraising process
we saw that the time it takes to close
around
was cut in half compared to the same
damage we've collected
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leomi tech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders the tech ecosystem is changing
so rapidly we've never
seen faster rate of change meet yael
benjamin the founder of why benjamin
strategic marketing
yael is the founder of startup snapshot
a data sharing platform working to
increase transparency in the startup
ecosystem
former investment banker turned
strategic advisor to innovators
she is on a mission to bring the same
level of analysis she saw in the
corporate world to startups
but in the flexible time frame and
formats that they need
with over a decade of experience in the
industry she has worked with hundreds of
startups helping them raise over a
billion dollars and counting
yell benjamin welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you doing
good thanks for having me thank you for
joining me
and we're going to talk about the
israeli ecosystem
and you know a lot of the times in the
show we're talking about
the different values the different
things that we're seeing in the trends
but now we're actually going to go down
to numbers
because through startup snapshot you're
actually coming
scientifically in a data-driven way
trying to understand what is happening
around us and i'm
so excited to dig deep into that so i'd
love for you to tell me a little bit
about you know what startup snapshot is
this project and then i would love to
hear before we get into the details how
you how you've actually
you know been bringing your expertise
from your previous organizations
into this project yeah definitely
um so startup snapshot started about a
year and a half ago
for the past 10 years i've been working
with startups helping them prepare for
fundraising
go to market strategy basically taking
my experience from before i worked
before in investment banking
and how do we kind of take that same
methodology and processes but condense
them for startups
so i've been working with a lot of
startups helping them you know prepare
to pitch investors prepare to penetrate
new markets
and i saw that the same questions were
coming up again and again
so you know it could be in terms of
benchmarks for fundraising best
practices
a lot of the questions back in the day
were around secondary transactions
you know at what stage can can founders
start selling
what's acceptable and i saw that there
was no organization that was collecting
this kind of data
and you know coming from the public
markets i like to depend on you know i'm
used to having a lot of
market research reports and analyst
reports and basically coming up with
conclusions based on that so i said okay
you know let's start collecting a little
bit of data
i reached out to my network and i saw
that there was a lot of
i don't know what to call demand but you
know the the startups were really
sharing
um and they were happy to share their
data and their insights and how they
were doing things
and i think they felt you know kind of
comfortable because it was anonymous
so i said to them you know share your
insights and then once i collect
everyone's data i'll share
the insights with the entire community
and that's kind of how the project
started
uh really you know really fast 400
companies i think it was in the
beginning
shared 400 founders shared all their you
know kind of uh private data about
fundraising
go to market yeah secondary transactions
options
so i said okay there's there's some kind
of a need here
so that's that's the way it started
incredible and
so you're taking you know you're getting
this really sensitive data that people
don't really
enjoy sharing you know the whole in you
know in private companies but by
anonymizing it by creating a win-win
situation where
what goes around comes around if you
share a little bit of your data
well you're going to get a lot more from
the ecosystem and it's just going to
help you grow and i think that's
fascinating
and so how does your experience from
investment banking and coming from these
worlds
how did it help you strategically think
through what what questions to even ask
or what would be interesting
for people in the israel ecosystem to
want to know
definitely so i i always come i always
came from the fundraising side so that
was kind of uh
the first step for me to understand you
know how long was the process taking
what was happening in the term sheets
different you know kind of metrics and
benchmarks but then i started talking to
a lot of vcs that i was working with
startups i was working with and kind of
asking them what are the pain points or
you know what do you need visibility on
and that's how
that's how we came to the list of
questions and we've released three
reports already
we're starting to work on the next one
and every time what's what's really
great is that it's
really relevant to what's happening at
that same moment so let's say
covid um you know started back in march
really fast we collected data from a
couple hundred startups and then we
shared the insights
with the entire community and everyone
was able to see you know in such an
uncertain time
um what was happening and what other
startups were doing kind of make better
decisions that way
incredible okay so i want to spend the
majority of the time getting to know the
israeli ecosystem really really well
this is going to be fascinating so
so walk me through a few of the major
insights that you've gained
as surprising or not and and i'd love to
also hear the rationale
of why that's why why that's the case
and what is some sort of
you know the thinking process that goes
on behind that
yeah so i can tell you you know the most
relevant things are from the last report
that we just launched
a couple of weeks ago so if we take for
example on the fundraising side
um so we checked term sheets we checked
uh statistics kind of the process
and we saw that you know the digital
pitch
kind of founders weren't able to fly
everyone was really worried about what
was going to happen the past couple of
months
but the digital pitch actually
accelerated uh the fundraising process
we saw that the time it takes to close
around
was cut in half compared to the same
damage collected
pre-covered um and obviously there's a
lot of money in the market so that's one
you know one driving force but the other
is the digital pitch that now you don't
have to drive
multiple times to you know to california
to meet with a vc
and manage the due diligence process you
can have a full
global road show you know from the
comfort comfort of your office in tel
aviv
and i think um from our stats 41 of the
startups
said that they never met their investors
face-to-face
really that closed around in the past
nine months
and it's incredible so it's a huge
opportunity and it's you know opening up
new sources of capital
accelerating the fundraising process but
it's also
you know especially for early stage
startups it's introducing kind of new
challenges
so one of the challenges we interviewed
a lot of startups and one of the
challenges we saw
was how to create credibility so for an
early stage startup you know you don't
have
it's not like in the us that someone
says you know i studied in stanford or
harvard or
some kind of stamp you know stamp of
approval so an israeli entrepreneur
is uh pitching investors that they don't
know abroad they don't have traction yet
they don't have a big vc backing them
a lot of them you know maybe even have
some kind of a prototype they don't have
a full product yet
so how do you create the sense of
credibility and that's um
that's that's a really interesting topic
we just had an event on that
with um some great entrepreneurs we
remember we spoke about that tommy
for magical shared his approach um
so kind of entrepreneurs had to adapt
and find creative ways
on how to create this credibility
incredible and so
as your as you're uncovering these
stories and these statistics it sounds
like you're actually taking it a step
further
and then actually digging deep with with
founders that are going and trying to
explain how these trends are looking
right
definitely so we collect the data on the
one hand um
and it's really nice i put together a
team of partners that works on this
together because
in the end of the day you know um the
more data we get the better it is for
everyone
so a couple of big players in the
ecosystem kind of really backed
this initiative um i have to thank
ifatto ron
she was back in the day she was the ceo
of lumitec and now she's opening up the
office of blackstone in israel so she
really
you know kind of saw the need in this
and back didn't help helped us collect a
lot of data
um intel ignite now fiverr a couple of
big organizations
so we collect a lot of data but on the
other hand we also interview a lot of
startups from different stages depending
on you know
what's relevant at that time and kind of
get their insight and try to understand
the more
qualitative insights behind it and how
they're you know what's their take on
kind of the data point we're collecting
very very cool okay i need some more
statistics teach me more
um so an interesting thing in the last
report because we looked into early
stage
startups what's one of the biggest
challenges um
you know for early startups these days
it's competing over talent
the israeli ecosystem is becoming very
expensive um it's rivaling you know
salaries in silicon valley
we found because of the rising value of
the shekel this past year
you know it versus the dollar there was
a huge jump
in in 2020. so 13 of them had to hire
employees abroad
and another large percent turned to
outsourcing so
for early stage startups it's kind of a
way to you know to scale and to grow
and and we got a lot of great insights
from michael the ceo of
fiverr because they were our partners on
it and you know he says it best he says
that this next
decade is going to be really focused on
how to integrate those freelance
you know uh workers into the companies
because there's a huge
reliance i think more than a third of
the companies said that
half their workforce is freelance of
these really
startups yeah and when you say early
stage startups
what stages are you talking about so so
we categorized it based on
you know amount of funding so those that
raised into until 10 million
so that was the total cut off wow and so
this is and this is the most recent
report right yeah that's from the last
couple of months
and so did this question come up in the
previous reports or is it something that
is new due to the emergence of the gig
economy
so i think it was definitely accelerated
um by covet and now that it's you know
possible to work remote so everyone's
saying
you know the israeli ecosystem is really
expensive it's positive you know it's
positive
possible to hire remote employees so why
not kind of leverage this trend
and a lot of companies are keeping their
core um
you know their core capabilities
in-house but kind of supporting it with
a whole
range of freelancers on the outside and
it's also you know besides
for the flexibility and the cost savings
it's also enabling them if we're talking
about credibility before
kind of how do you create credibility
abroad so you know now you have some
kind of a webinar
you can get you know a team of
freelancers to create a really
professional
editing company video kind of packaging
for this webinar
and you seem like a much bigger company
than you really are so now
early stage companies can kind of brand
themselves and
you know kind of scale but they don't
have to keep everything in-house
right that makes a lot of sense talk to
me about secondaries this is a topic
that
is definitely under discussed and there
is some some sort of it
feels like a black black hole that that
you know
we don't really know and don't really
publicize about yet it's obviously
something that is
you know occupying a lot of investors a
lot of founders a lot of employees
what what what are what are secondaries
first of all and then and then
what have you what have you learned
about secondaries in the market yeah
so you know general overview it's
usually when you're starting a startup
you get some sort of you know the
founder or the team that has options can
kind of cash out when there's a
liquidation event
when you're selling the company when you
have an ipo
any kind of you know final transaction
that's happening and it's become more
acceptable nowadays that the founders or
employees were saying senior management
cashes out a bit before
and as we're moving you know in the past
couple of years from startup nation to
scale up nation
you have to give the kind of the
management team that's putting in all
this hard effort some sort of
breathing you know breathing room kind
of give them incentive to keep growing
and keep growing these big companies
and not just you know starting a startup
and selling quickly within a couple of
years
so it's interesting we gathered data on
this about a year and a half ago
so what i have to say honestly for that
isn't so relevant but you know we're now
starting a new data collection effort so
i think we'll include that and then we
could compare in the past year and a
half with all the craziness you know
that's happened
what's uh what's the benchmark were
there things that came up that were
really surprising something that you
think that the average entrepreneur
wouldn't you know wouldn't necessarily
understand or or
have intuition about hmm um
i think the things that we're collecting
yeah it's it's sort of benchmarks let's
say now
um it was always common practice for an
entrepreneur for one of the founding
team to move
abroad so you know what do you do in
covid the past couple of months or the
year
past year you know less less
entrepreneurs are moving abroad
so an interesting trend we saw is the
rise of the remote first organization
which that's kind of a shift in thinking
where everyone in israel is always like
you know i have to be new york i have to
be in london i have to be in silicon
valley but
is there room for this new type of
organization where the whole management
team
you know super social was interviewed in
our report and that's a great example i
think they have
25 employees from 25 different countries
and everyone is
sitting yeah everyone's sitting
separately and
the company managed to raise a lot of
funding grow really quickly
and it's just a different way of
thinking it was a strategic decision
from day one
and that's even when things go back to
normal you know jonathan the ceo says
that's kind of our vision going forward
very very cool
so as you go and i'm guessing now you're
working on your fourth report right
yeah so if anyone has if you have any
ideas or if anyone has any topics that
they want to include then definitely
feel free to reach out so that's a good
segue to my to my question so as you're
now going about your fourth report and
it's your you know it's
proper data you know data collection
data science and
and it sounds like a very difficult
thing to do as well especially
normalizing all the data
and how have you evolved your thinking
through these reports
as you're now approaching your fourth
one now more on the strategic level how
have you
changed your thinking yeah um i think
you know the days of like these heavy
reports kind of top down
market overview you know like the 60
page reports those days are kind of gone
and i want to find ways to make this
these insights or these tips like that
the data coming from the ground from the
from the founders themselves to really
make it more accessible to everyone
so i think that's the direction that
it's going of you know how do we give
more entrepreneurs
access to this content but not just you
know data points
but more what can they do with it what's
the story of a founder like them how did
he tackle this kind of an issue
and what you can do going forward so i
think right
and and about tell me about the
accessibility of this information and
how you're
how you're thinking through you know who
who reads this
why they read this when they read this
yeah so
you know from from the efforts that
we've had so far it's a lot of founders
that are kind of looking to see you know
before they're making an important
decision to say okay what's happening in
the ecosystem you know what are other
companies doing
and a lot of also general ecosystem
players a lot of vcs a lot of you know
all the
um accounting firms law firms
so it's just a gener i think a general
awareness kind of of what's happening in
the market today because until today a
lot of the data was very siloed
um so a lot of the let's say the vc
funds would kind of collect it for their
own entrepreneurs and it was based on
that specific data but it was accessible
also to those entrepreneurs
and there wasn't a full market approach
to it i mean i'm thinking about all the
different questions that i that i get
often asked
and i don't have the answers to them and
that's exactly what i tell the people
but they're asking me a lot of these
types of questions is it acceptable to
start a company remote is it accessible
to sell secondaries this stage is it
acceptable to raise
this amount of money or to bootstrap
until this point because
you know a lot it sounds to me that a
lot of the things that we're we're
experiencing
is through the media and through the
articles in the newspapers which
don't tend to really tell the full
picture of what the ecosystem is like
right they often even tell the outliers
and the edge cases that aren't
conforming to the normalcy
definitely and and in the end you have
to remember it's it's
press so you know it's telling a story
with a certain
uh certain kind of twist to it right
right and and so it sounds like you're
doing a big service to especially a lot
of younger and
and and perhaps less experienced
entrepreneurs that are trying to even
figure out
how does the world work and as and you
know one of the things that i've been
thinking about
you know with entrepreneurship and with
leadership in general as you progress
with your company you're you're
encountered by these new problems that
you've never had done before the better
you are
or the more you succeed the less
experienced you become because you have
to deal with new challenges and
and reports like these can actually be
really really beneficial
so thank you for doing that and i'm
excited to read them on my own i think
it's also that the
markets nowadays are evolving so quickly
like you know back in the day you can
say
you know this is the way it's been done
for the past you know five six seven
years but that's not
it's not relevant anymore you know now
things are happening in short bursts of
this is a situation for a couple of
months you know think about half a year
ago how we saw the world
and how we're seeing the huge jump in
investments now and you know kind of the
frenzy in the market so it's
it's really short kind of sprints and
you have to know what's relevant
kind of hop on the wave in that very
short amount of time
100 100 yeah this was so wonderful thank
you for
sharing those insights with me i really
enjoyed it i have a few more questions
not about
startup snapshot or not about this this
data
collection but but it's more about you
and i want you to take me back to your
childhood
tell me what what really fascinated you
as a kid what perhaps a favorite subject
the fashion hobby
wow so for me i was always like a
literature nerd
in the end um i studied even in
undergrad i studied psychology and
literature so for me it was like
going to english class you know i like
everyone was reading the cliff notes and
i was really
reading the books for fun and that's
until today like when i
i find a really good book and i can say
okay now you know this weekend i don't
want to do anything besides for finish
this book
and that's a that's amazing for me
really really cool
and some figure of inspiration or role
model throughout your journey
professionally or personally
um i i think stefan sagmeister um
he's a really famous austrian graphic
designer
and you know now that i'm working it's
funny because i'm from like the business
you know i'm helping startups with
fundraising
but a lot of the work that we do i have
a team of graphic designers so a lot of
the work that we do is how do we take
you know boring stats and turn them into
kind of use infographics use
illustrations use different design
elements to turn them into something
interesting
and that's what um that's what he does
he had an amazing exhibit the happiness
project i think it was called or
something like that where he took data
on what makes someone happy and then he
used different
you know like graphic design elements to
show and it was
very very very cool and what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
ah three words um i think ambitious
because everything when i decide on
something it takes me maybe time to
decide but when i decide i
i go for it um i would hope generous
you ask the friends and family around me
um and energetic
a lot of stuff a lot
thank you very very much this is
wonderful and
the reports i mean they really are doing
a great service i think the ecosystem
and especially as
you know if things as things are
changing much quicker than before at an
accelerated pace
i think it's going to become more and
more relevant for us to to keep a strong
foothold on what's happening and be able
to even just think through these trends
and understand are we happy with these
trends are we not happy with these
trends
you know again these are impacting the
entire ecosystem and not just every
startup on its own
and so thank you for the great work
you're doing thank you thank you for
having me wonderful
thank you
you